[Music]
you're watching swipe coming up on this
week's show pushing light past the limit
Thomas takes a look at a cutting-edge
microscope a decade since we first got
our fingers on the iPhone has Apple
fallen behind in the innovation race and
Lucy looks at the return of a legend in
our games review welcome to swipe now a
lots changed in 10 years it's hard to
believe that back then smartphones and
apps as we know them didn't even exist
and yet now they're everywhere and
competition for your palm among the tech
giants is fiercer than ever
so decade on I'm looking back at the
game-changing release of the original
iPhone but first Thomas has been to see
a cutting-edge British invention that
could revolutionize the field of
nanotech research the most powerful
optical microscope in the world called
monopsonist british made invention has
managed to increase magnification power
400% beyond what was previously thought
possible for the first time scientists
will be able to study things as small as
viruses and a visible light in real time
and in full color
the reason this device works is because
of the use of microspheres can you tell
me what is a microsphere microsphere
here means it's very small transparent
spherical Lance's these type of small
Lance's are not new to us in nature you
can see flies mosquitoes or other
insects the eyeballs are very very small
microspheres you can see the world
differently from what we will see but
this is the first time of use at this
type of microsphere lenses as a part of
microscopes the applications are
far-reaching research into cancer
medicine the discovery of new drugs or
work on microchip technology this
technology has the potential to be a
game-changer in R&D essentially
combating all of
key problems that are faced in terms of
imaging in R&D facilities where you're
looking at accessibility issues on very
high-end equipment and getting access to
super resolution capabilities or whether
it's cost and then also ease-of-use
scientists and academics often find
themselves at the back of long queues
waiting to use powerful and complicated
electron microscopes this bit of kit
aims to remove those barriers and at a
fraction of the cost okay Thomas what do
you think this is I'm looking at it and
it looks it looks almost like veins but
I'm pretty sure veins would be too big
on a nano nano scale so I'll say
something like a another microchip
processor it's in fact a butterfly week
a butterfly wing yes indeed some of the
earliest things to be stuck under
microscopes were animals specimens like
these butterflies here at the Natural
History Museum fast forward to today and
microscopy and nanotechnology are
crucial for scientific research and the
UK has fast become a hub for such
innovations in the UK we we lead
nanotechnology research in many areas we
have some of the some of the best
scientists in the world and some of the
best universities and the government has
historically funded us very well it's
estimated that the sector that nonnatus
inhabits will be worth five billion
pounds by 2020 having a firm grip on
this market is a key goal for British
innovators Thomas Newton Sky News time
for a closer look at what else has been
going on in the world of tech this week
here's all you need to know a global
cyber attack spread from Ukraine to more
than 60 countries cybersecurity experts
now say it aimed to destroy data and not
to make money companies around the world
were hits ranging from British
Advertising giant WPP to FedEx is TNT
express service to a chocolate factory
in Australia while it was originally
described as ransomware experts now say
the virus made it impossible to recover
data Eve
fee was paid Google has been fined more
than two billion pounds for abusing its
dominance as a search engine to promote
its own service EU regulators say the
search giant breached antitrust rules by
listing its own shopping comparison
service at the top of search results
Google disagreed and may now appeal the
decision Facebook has hit two billion
users every month around a quarter of
the world's population mark zuckerberg
said the social network could fill the
gap left by falling church membership
and offer people a sense of community
but while the user base has been growing
so too has pressure on the social
network to crack down on fake news and
extremist content and how is your
internet connection well this week we
found out as the best and worst
broadband speeds across the UK were
revealed
Tamworth in the West Midlands was the
fastest area while rural areas in
Scotland came bottom at the table
overall the consumer group which said
far too many of us was still struggling
with slow broadband it's hard to imagine
a world without well the world in the
palm of your hand but just ten years ago
that's what it was like if you wanted to
know where you were going while calling
a friend and listening to some music
you'd have taken with you a handful of
devices and you can forget about swiping
to find the love of your life or playing
on the App Store I mean those things
didn't even exist but then along came
one device that would change everything
[Applause]
i phone fever swept the world some even
called it the Jesus phone so great was
the height and when it was finally
released in June 2007 sales soared by
the end of the year around 1.4 million
handsets were sold now Apple have sold
more than a billion but last year they
reported the first ever decline in
iPhone sales and competition in the
smartphone market is now fiercer than
ever so how far has the iPhone come it
was just the first time the world had
really seen this form factor the whole
idea of having what's called a
multi-touch display so you can do want
more than one finger input at a time
it's like zoom pinch maps and stuff and
just originally when Steve Jobs first
showed this off just swiping on a screen
reading text was just revolutionary and
it had been done on other phones but
just not quite as well as they're being
done here and also the fact you could
get me internet so now when we think of
smart phones and iPhones we think apps
we think the App Store but when it first
came out it was quite limited in what
you could do it wasn't it yeah Steve
Jobs originally didn't want to have an
app store he would give on any third
parties to develop apps for the platform
because he was a bit of a control freak
in a good way though because it has
meant that the rest of the line has
benefitted from a closed operating
system but it took a whole year until
June 2008 for there even to be
third-party apps on the iPhone could it
be said that Apple started to sort of
lose the innovation race yeah there's
definite argument for that and Apple
fans much like Android fans are very
dedicated to their brand and there is
nothing wrong with an iPhone it'll still
do everything you want to do but it
lacks things perhaps like while it's
charging yes yes is also the first
iPhone the iPhone 7 which was in anyway
waterproof and it's things that Android
phones have been doing for a while now
such as this so this is Samsung's latest
phone the Galaxy sa this is the plus
model which is why it's so huge but you
can see in comparison to the iPhone kind
of the way that a company a rival
company is kind of improved screen
technology to basically take up entire
front of the device it's video games
time is Lucy with the week's top picks
crash bandicoot is a PlayStation icon
and around 20 years ago he was like the
face of the PlayStation brand and
now he's back he's first three games are
being remade completely it's a
platforming game where you place a
spinning bandicoot and there's loads of
colourful crazy characters that you have
to sort of meet and defeat as you go
through these really colourful gorgeous
world and they've modernized it slightly
so it's still got all the platforming
fun that you remember but now it has
things like automatic checkpoints if you
kind of want to relive that childhood
and replay crash bandicoot then you can
with the enzyme trilogy or if you've
never played Crash Bandicoot before you
should definitely pick it up because
it's one of the classic most famous
platforms around so you might remember
Micro Machines as the small toy cars
that you could play with when you're a
kid but they also had a very successful
line of video games and the latest Micro
Machines World Series is out this week
it's a kind of a top-down look and all
the tracks are really awesome and they
are sort of representative of sort of
real world so there's a one in a garden
or there's one on the kitchen countertop
and you know breakfast is being made on
it's a pool table so it's kind of this
really nice mix of video gaming life but
I say real life quite hesitantly because
it's all-out bombastic action and you
can smash the cars into into other ones
and make them explode and you can play
by yourself
offline or you can play online with a
bunch of friends that's what I was doing
yesterday we all had our own cars each
car has a different kind of personality
and way that it drives if you played it
when you were younger it's still the
core of the game that you remember but
now it has cool online modes so that's
out this week also
The Legend of Zelda the breath of the
wild is one of the best games to come
out this year so far and it's finally
getting its first piece of downloadable
content the master Trials so it adds a
whole bunch of new things to the game
first of all it adds a new hard mode so
when you played Zelda originally it
would just kind of be on like an even
plane and it wouldn't ever really get
that tricky but now you can start a new
game and it'll be hard from the get-go
so enemies they'll be tougher they have
regenerating health they can see you
from further away which makes the game
more tactical and a lot more kind of
challenging to play which is quite cool
but the big thing coming out of this DLC
is the fact that has the master trials
which is so you have the master sword
which is the best sword in the game and
if you complete the master trials which
is a challenge where there's 45 or so
rooms and you start with absolutely
nothing no weapons no armor no no food
or anything and you have to defeat all
of the enemies and if you defeat all
forty five rooms worth of enemies then
your master sword is powered up which if
you're like me and you kind of want to
do everything in the game will be really
cool so that is finally coming up this
week well that's it for this week's
swipe but you can catch all of our past
episodes upon our YouTube playlist and
of course get all the latest tech news
from sky news wherever you are on TV on
Facebook on Twitter on snapchat our
website and our app we'll see you again
next time bye bye
you
[Music]